you know who else is in the movie with
Jamie though Nancy brie Larson and she's
also been hitting the gym part because
brie is also the first woman to lead a
Marvel movie in Captain Marvel so you're
not from around here it's hard to
explain
exclusively on set of Captain Marvel
y'all ready I'm ready
please tell me that you had a moment
when you put this on I did get emotional
but what's crazy the movies are so
secretive it's like don't get to share
the dance and I can share it now you can
be like oh my god think of Captain
Marvel as the ultimate show of girl
power Brie's an elite air fighter pilot
with off-the-charts alien powers enough
to throw down with Robert Downey jr.
Iron Man and Chris Hemsworth store I'm
not what you think I am I was an
introvert with asthma before this movie
so I was like I gotta get you know get
it together for this so I carved out
nine months to train and kind of retool
everything joining brie in the Marvel
origin story is Jude Law who plays her
mentor and samuel l.jackson digital
magic alter sam's look by three decades
what's going on with the dots you know
these dots on my botox
I look younger by the time the movie job
I did a couple movies in the 90s that
they can go back and kind of use that
face you gonna make them let you take
this honestly it smells so bad
I'm not sure I want it oh you want to
take one home and here's the cornball in
me Nancy when I walked on that set I was
walking like
you
[Music]